Tengo una pregunta.
Si te hablo de la Unión Europea, ¿Qué es
lo primero en lo que piensas?
Probablemente lo primero que se te venga a
la cabeza sean imágenes de Bruselas, edificios
públicos o, incluso, estampas de países
tan importantes en la unión como Alemania
o Francia.
Hasta es probable que, dependiendo de dónde
nos veas, pienses, antes en el Reino Unidos
que en países como, por ejemplo, Lituania
o Eslovenia.
Y de hecho, en 2018, se hizo una encuesta
en 26 países de todo el mundo, cuyos resultados
señalaban que los 3 estados de la Unión
más importantes son, por este orden, Alemania,
Francia y el Reino Unido.
En cuarta posición les seguía bastante de
lejos Italia.
Todos ellos tienen como denominador común
que son países de la Europa Occidental.
Y lo cierto es que por mucha Unión que exista,
sobre el terreno aún existe una marcada frontera
entre las dos europas tan distintas que hoy
por hoy integran la Unión Europea.
Hablamos de percepciones, pero también de
infraestructuras y profundas diferencias políticas,
sociales y económicas.
Y esto es algo que preocupa cada vez más
en la “otra Europa” la Europea Central
y Oriental.
Y diréis, pero, ¿qué es eso de las naciones
de los tres mares?
Pues, queridos amigos, amigas, la iniciativa
de los tres mares es un proyecto que fue creado
precisamente para resolver todos estos problemas.
Viendo su nombre, quizás penséis que tiene
que ver con algo marítimo, ¿no?
Pues, lo siento pero no, nada de eso.
La iniciativa se llama así porque une a doce
países de la Unión Europea ubicados entre
tres mares distintos: el mar Báltico por
el norte, el Negro por el sudeste y el Adriático
por el sudoeste.
Hablamos de Austria, Bulgaria, Croacia, Eslovaquia,
Eslovenia, Estonia, Hungría, Letonia, Lituania,
Polonia, República Checa y Rumania.
Se trata de una plataforma creada en 2015
para llevar a cabo proyectos en tres ámbitos:
infraestructuras, energía y telecomunicaciones.
¿Su objetivo?
Fomentar el crecimiento económico de la región.
Y ya os adelanto que, a pesar de ser bastante
reciente, la iniciativa de los 3 mares ha
dado lugar a más de una polémica, tanto
dentro como fuera de la Unión Europea.
Sintetizando, cuenta con el apoyo de los Estados
Unidos, cabrea a Rusia y preocupa a algunos
países de la UE.
Pero ¿de dónde sale este proyecto?
¿En qué consiste exactamente?
¿Hasta dónde puede realmente llegar?
¿Puede quizás convertirse incluso en una
amenaza para la propia Unión Europea, al
menos tal y como hoy la conocemos?
Pues… Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
Tal y como hemos comentado, la iniciativa
de los 3 mares une a toda una franja de países
que van desde Estonia hasta Bulgaria.Y desde
luego, la idea de conectar el norte y el sur
de Europa es de todo menos nueva.
Lo que no cambia en esta ocasión es su promotor
principal, que no es otro que Polonia:
Andrzej Duda es el presidente de Polonia,
el país que junto con Croacia ha lanzado
la iniciativa de los tres mares.
Y me diréis, “pero ¿qué diantres pinta
aquí el siglo 17?”.
Pues este mapa lo explica todo.
(Lo que vemos en verde es el territorio de
la mancomunidad polaco-lituana.
Hablamos de un Estado federal creado por la
Unión de Lublin en el año 1569, y que llegó
a su máximo esplendor en el siglo 17.
Para Polonia, se trata de una época dorada,
algo así como el siglo XX para Hollywood.
Sin embargo, la mancomunidad como tal tuvo
una historia muy corta.
A finales del siglo 18, este territorio vio
no una, sino tres particiones entre sus grandes
vecinos: Austria, Prusia y Rusia.
Como consecuencia, tanto Polonia como Lituania
no volvieron a ser independientes hasta la
Primera Guerra Mundial.
En 1918 se creó la Segunda República Polaca,
un Estado independiente, que sin embargo no
tenía nada que ver con la grandeza del siglo
17.
Y fue precisamente ahí cuando cobró peso
la idea de recrear, de una u otra forma, la
antigua mancomunidad.)
Como habría dicho Donald Trump si hubiera
nacido en la Varsovia de la época, “Znowu
uczynić Polskę wielką”.
O para que nos entendamos todos, “Make Poland
great again”.
Aunque lo cierto es que para hacer esta promesa,
no hizo falta un Donald Trump.
Porque la Segunda República Polaca ya contaba
con un líder totalmente mentalizado con este
mensaje, hablamos de Józef Piłsudski.
[Jiusef Piususki]
Piłsudski fue el primer jefe de Estado de
la Polonia del siglo XX, y su gran preocupación
se situaba en el este.
En el Imperio ruso primero y, más tarde,
en la Unión Soviética.
De hecho, bajo el mando de Piłsudski, Polonia
libró una guerra de dos años contra las
futuras repúblicas de la URSS.
Y, claro, la gran pregunta es: ¿qué podía
hacer un país como Polonia para sobrevivir?
Pues..
Piłsudski tenía dos propuestas.
La primera opción consistía en romper al
enemigo desde dentro.
Ya sabéis que en lo que se refiere a las
nacionalidades, el Imperio ruso y, más tarde
el proyecto comunista eran de todo menos homogéneos.
De esta forma, la idea de Piłsudski, que
recibió el nombre de prometeismo, consistía
en promover las actitudes antirrusas y antisoviéticas
entre los diferentes pueblos que integraban
la URRS.
Pero, sin embargo, el proyecto de Piłsudski
que más importa en este vídeo es el llamado
Intermarium, que abarcaba el territorio que
se encuentra entre los mares Báltico, Negro
y Adriático.
¿A qué nos suena esta franja?
Exacto, son los mismos países que participan
hoy en la iniciativa de los 3 mares.
(Intermarium, o Międzymorze, en polaco, fue
un proyecto de federación política entre
los países situados en el territorio de la
antigua mancomunidad polaco-lituana.
De esta forma, Piłsudski pretendía crear
un nuevo núcleo de poder regional, y encontrar
la fuerza en la unión.
Eso sí, con Polonia como la voz cantante.
Esta idea fue desarrollada por otros políticos
polacos en el período de entreguerras, pero
la verdad es que no encontró suficientes
apoyos en el exterior.
Terminó convirtiéndose en un proyecto fallido.)
Pero, entonces, ¿Por qué estamos hablando
de él en VisualPolitik?
Pues porque, para muchos analistas, las ideas
de Piłsudski son el antecedente más claro
de la iniciativa de los 3 mares.
Juzgad por vosotros mismos: hablamos del mismo
territorio, cierto antagonismo con Rusia y
un proyecto con el que Polonia tiene mucho
que ganar.
Sin embargo, existe una diferencia muy importante
entre Intermarium y la iniciativa de los 3
mares.
Y es que Piłsudski pensaba en la integración
de los países de la región, con las vertientes
geopolítica y militar como la base del proyecto.
En cambio, la iniciativa de los 3 mares ya
no es un proyecto de integración, sino de
coordinación, y tiene un trasfondo mucho
más económico.
Pero, un momento, aquí tenemos que hacer
una puntualización:
Es verdad que la nueva iniciativa no prevé
cooperación en materia militar.
Pero también es cierto que, a excepción
de Austria, todos los países de la iniciativa
de los 3 mares también son miembros de la
OTAN.
Además, nueve de ellos forman parte de una
agrupación regional conocida como los Nueve
de Bucarest.
El B9 fue creado en 2015 a propuesta de Rumanía
y Polonia, y tiene como objetivo armonizar
las preferencias regionales en el seno de
la OTAN.
En otras palabras, si combinamos la iniciativa
de los tres mares con la membresía de estos
países en la OTAN y en el B9, entonces lo
que tenemos es un proyecto mucho más parecido
al Intermarium de Piłsudski.
Ahora bien, llegados a este punto, estoy seguro
de que aún tenéis muchas dudas: ¿qué es
exactamente lo que implica esta iniciativa?
¿Por qué le interesa tanto a Polonia?
Y ¿qué consecuencias puede tener para la
región y para el exterior?”.
Atentos.
(CONECTANDO EUROPA)
En 2015, los presidentes de Polonia y de Croacia
acordaron crear la Iniciativa de los 3 mares.
Hay que entender que de momento no se trata
de una nueva organización internacional,
sino de una plataforma informal.
Hasta ahora, la Iniciativa ha celebrado cinco
cumbres anuales, y la sexta tendrá lugar
en Bulgaria en julio de 2021.
Su objetivo principal consiste en fomentar
el crecimiento económico en la región y
reducir su dependencia energética de Rusia.
Por eso sus 3 tipos de proyectos clave son
los de transporte, telecomunicaciones y energía.
(A día de hoy, hablamos de 90 proyectos en
distintas fases de desarrollo.
Por ejemplo, uno de los proyectos propuestos
por Hungría es la llamada “Conexión norte-sur”.
Como indica su nombre, consiste en crear un
corredor de transporte desde Suecia hasta
Grecia, que pasaría a través de Polonia,
República Checa, Eslovaquia, Hungría, Croacia,
Serbia, Montenegro y Macedonia.
Y aunque, algunos de estos países ni siquiera
forman parte de la Iniciativa de los 3 mares,
lo que importa aquí es el objetivo último:
fomentar la conectividad entre el norte y
el sur de la franja centro-oriental de Europa.
En el ámbito digital, también tenemos proyectos
muy interesantes, en materias tan variadas
como el 5G, la ciberseguridad y el monitoreo
en tiempo real de cuencas hidrográficas.)
Pero quizás el sector más importante es
el de la energía.
Si sois seguidores asiduos de VisualPolitik,
conocéis bien el tema de la seguridad energética
en Europa.
Y también sabéis cuál es una de sus principales
fuentes de gas.
Por supuesto, me refiero a
El 40% de todo el gas que importa la Unión
Europea viene de Rusia.
Como podéis ver, el gas ruso es especialmente
importante para algunos de los países de
la iniciativa de los 3 mares.
Lo que se traduce en una herramienta geopolítica
de incalculable valor para Moscú.
Precisamente por esto, países como Estonia,
Letonia o Croacia están trabajando en la
creación de terminales de gas natural licuado
que les permita no depender de los gasoductos
y por tanto del gas ruso.
El gas natural licuado o GNL se transporta
en gigantescos buques metaneros.
Y la ventaja de este sistema consiste en que
abre muchas nuevas vías de importación.
Por ejemplo, desde 2017 Polonia importa gas
natural licuado de los Estados Unidos.
Hasta aquí suena genial, ¿verdad?
Pues, stop, ha llegado el momento de hablar
del principal problema de la Iniciativa de
los 3 mares.
Y es que algunos de los proyectos, por ejemplo,
el corredor Norte-Sur, se encuentran suspendidos
porque no está nada claro cómo y cuándo
se van a implementar.
Y, sobre todo, de dónde demonios saldrá
el dinero para financiarlo.
Recordad que ni siquiera hablamos de una estructura
formal.
A día de hoy, solo se han finalizado dos
de los 90 proyectos, y ambos eran de alcance
nacional.
¿La solución?
En teoría, podría ser esta:
(Los bancos de Polonia y de Rumanía establecen
el fondo de inversiones de la Iniciativa de
los Tres Mares.
Emerging-Europe)
El Fondo de Inversiones fue creado en junio
del 2019 y es la primera institución formal
creada en el marco de esta iniciativa.
Inicialmente fue dotado con 520 millones de
euros, una cifra que ha ido creciendo hasta
los 1.200 millones en el momento de preparar
este vídeo.
Claro que aún está lejos de su primer objetivo,
el cual se sitúa en los 3.000 millones de
euros.
La idea es que este fondo financie en sus
primeras etapas entorno al 9% de las inversiones
planteadas,El resto de la financiación tendrá
que llegar de arcas nacionales y de fondos
europeos, tales como el Banco Europeo de Inversiones,
el Banco Europeo para la Reconstrucción y
el Desarrollo y el Mecanismo Conectar Europa.
Claro que si para algo ha servido ya este
fondo ha sido para constatar que la I3M, la
iniciativa de los Tres Mares, empieza a despertar
interés fuera de la región.
Fijaos.
(300 millones de dólares para el Fondo de
inversión de la iniciativa de los Tres Mares
de la Corporación Financiera de Desarrollo
Internacional de los Estados Unidos.)
Queridos amigos, amigas: ¿Por qué le interesa
tanto a los Estados Unidos?
¿Hasta qué punto amenaza a la estabilidad
dentro de la Unión Europea?
¿Qué tiene todo esto que ver con Rusia?
Atentos.
(RIESGO DE INUNDACIONES)
La I3M aún siendo muy nueva está ya empezando
a suscitar reacciones de todo tipo.
Y es que no hablamos de poca cosa.
En su conjunto, la I3M está formada por 12
de los 27 países de la UE, lo que supone
el 25% de la población comunitaria y el 28%
de su territorio.
Además, a excepción de Austria, todos estos
países han entrado en la Unión Europea a
partir de 2004. de forma, su historia como
parte de la UE es bastante reciente.
Por eso, la creación de esta iniciativa ha
sido vista desde algunos países como un intento
de desafiar a la Europa de los 15, es decir,
a los Estados que formaban parte de la UE
antes del 2004.
Esta es por así decirlo, la otra Europa que
acoge la Unión Europea, una Europa muy diferente
a la que estamos acostumbrados.
Una Europa que no siempre está cómoda con
Bruselas.
Ahora bien, ¿Quiere decir eso que estamos
ante un proyecto que puede hacer temblar los
cimientos de la Unión Europea?
Pues, siendo justos, de momento hay que decir
que no parece que en el corto plazo vaya a
ser una amenaza para la Unión Europea.
De momento no hablamos de una estructura formal,
los pacto aún tienen un alcance limitado
y además no todos los países están alineados
en la misma dirección.
Por ejemplo, Eslovaquia y la República Checa
no forman parte todavía del Fondo de inversiones
de la I3M.
Y esto se explica, en parte, por su recelo
ante Polonia y, en menor medida, Hungría.
Y, además, la financiación de los proyectos
que se están poniendo en marcha depende hoy
por hoy en gran medida de los fondos europeos.
Pero un momento, eso no quiere decir que esta
iniciativa no pueda tener en el medio plazo
importantes consecuencias.
La I3M puede contribuir a cohesionar a los
países de Europa del Este, empujarles en
una misma dirección y hacer crecer su peso
en Bruselas.
Incluso, llegado el caso, podría ser todo
un contrapeso o podrían marcar líneas rojas.
No olvidéis toda la historia del Brexit.
Por ejemplo, los planes energéticos e la
I3M chocan con el NordStream 2.
Hace poco os contábamos en VisualPolitik
que NordStream 2 es un gasoducto que pronto
llevará gas ruso a Alemania, a pesar de las
críticas que suscita en Europa Central.
Y justo aquí entra en juego otro actor: los
Estados Unidos.
(“Mientras Rusia espera mantener a nuestros
aliados europeos como rehenes con su gasoducto
Nord Stream 2, la Iniciativa de los Tres Mares
busca contrarrestar su influencia maligna”.
Adam Kinzinger, Miembro de la Cámara de Representantes
de los Estados Unidos)
Para Washington, apoyar la Iniciativa de los
3 Mares es una buena oportunidad para contrarrestar
la influencia rusa en la región.
Tanto es así que en noviembre de 2020 la
Cámara de Representantes de los Estados Unidos
aprobó por unanimidad una resolución a favor
de la I3M.
Por eso no es de sorprender que el proyecto
preocupe en Rusia, que sospecha que los tres
mares europeos podrían ahogar sus intereses
en la región.
Por ejemplo, en opinión del embajador ruso
en Estonia, la Iniciativa de los 3 mares podría
convertirse en un cordón sanitario antirruso.
Ya sabéis que está Europa está mucho más
conectada con Washington de lo que ultimamente
viene siendo habitual en la antigua parte
occidental.
Amigos, Europa del Este tiene cada vez más
peso: su economía prospera y su peso político
crece.
Iniciativas como esta, aún cuando se enfrente
a problemas de todo tipo para arrancar, pueden
terminar convirtiendose en todo un punto de
inflexión para la política del viejo continente.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, pregunta para ti:
¿conocíais la Iniciativa de los 3 mares?
¿Creéis que podrá llevar a cabo todos sus
proyectos?
¿Creéis que puede llegar a ser una amenaza
para la Unión Europea?
Podéis dejar vuestras respuestas en los comentarios.
Y ta sabéis si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante no olvideis darle a like y suscribiros
a VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.